じゃあみんな今日はですね今
すっごいん
中途半端なーん
色なんですよ
そうちょっとサイロみたいな感じなんで僕はもうね本当に
言っちゃあ言っちゃなんですけど大学生活も長くないラウンド仕事にいつかわからない
けどきっとねー
いやわかんないけどねぇー
そんなも激しい色にはできないと思うんだよね職種によるかもしれないんですけどなん
かね
ここ合わせたねちょっとね大津綾香るゆくー
して大学生活を締めくくろうかなと思いまして
水色のビデオで髪の毛よそれを
ん
どんな色になるか分からんだよと色の変化を見ててくる今こんな色です
お前でみんなを得て覚えて光栄だね覚えたねもう見せないよするんですね
経てもヒントあげないからで添えていきますから
よす
さていきますよ僕と販促黒くないっしょ
黒気ないんですけど
なんか顔だね多分
ちゃんと大学行ってるから開けするんですよねあんまり調べない人には黒が実はヤワな
いっていうのが僕の中のかってなぁ
大澤勝手ですね
もう全然しなんか最近クリーム型機にし色とわー
これだ
などはなるでしょ
もう頭に来たこれはもう完全に今吹っ切れたぞハンそうでしょ
あそこで取り出すとかもうちゃえ議論は付であるある
もうをしたねー現役つけるかねぇ
もう頭打ちからなぁ
まあ
イライラするあ4液晶がー
web
ていた
うふふ
ブーフの
ん
とぅん
次の一つぞイソメを破ったねー
洗いながら時間を置いて洗い流して皮が車道からスタートです
つかもよはいそれましたーーー
j a これよっとしているこれか
どうすか
色的なアレはちょっとわからないと思うんですね結構明るいんですよほらっ
そしてなんか blitz したら大うけなぁ何か良い具合にパサパサしてこれボケ
さんも
バックスも何もしてないんですよデフォルトでこれですよ
そんな明るてもないし暗くはないで警官
倉木麻衣って感じです
終わるかなぁん
伝わらないよねー
こんな感じですこれわかりやすいかもしれない
さっきと比べてもやっぱちょっと明るいんですよ
ぎゃっ釣りのビデオ
なかなかいい感じなんで是非初めてみてください
じゃ